Let's talk a bit more
about Setting Good KPIs.
A Key Performance Indicator or KPI is
a measurable value that demonstrates
how effectively a company is achieving
their key business objectives.
Organizations use KPIs to evaluate
their success at reaching targets.
As opposed to metrics,
which simply demonstrate the current
state of events of a company.
How much money they're making,
how many customers that they have.
KPIs clearly indicate where actions for
change should be taken.
For example,
you could set KPIs to measure
increases in customer satisfaction.
You could also look at app installations
per whatever days, ten, 15, 30, 100.
You can also look at the number
of active users after 30 days.
The important aspect when selecting KPIs
is to ensure that they're tied to your
own business objectives.
It's a good idea to be agile here and
to customize your KPIs as you
progress with your startup.
So take a minute and think about some
of the KPIs that you might set for
your product.
And then,
how might you evaluate whether or
not the KPIs that you've
selected are the right ones?
Use this box to record your response.